the color is the most special internally
flawless and then the size of 12 carats
but I would say to me the most rare part
of the stone is the fact that it's such
an exquisite perfectly so yes or how
rare is it to find something that has a
sort of deep ocean blue color that stone
is historical it's absolutely beautiful
you do get different you know colors of
blue but that's a special special blue
and so that how you got the name blue
moon diamond yeah woman yeah once in a
blue moon because really that's how rate
is I mean I've never seen a stone in
this color in my life in diamonds Wow so
I feel yeah I feel privileged this is
the highlight of my career and talk us
through that process a little bit you
start off with with the raw diamonds and
it how does it get to be this perfect
shape so when the rough arrives what we
do is our cutter studies that our
gemologist studies it he makes models
out of plastic and he then marks it
because on a rough stone you mark where
you're going to cut and put it on the
wheel so he's cutting the model and the
reason for this is if we make a mistake
it's not costing us millions of dollars
and so he'll make like 20 to 30 models
and he'll keep cutting them and you want
the stone to be internally flawless so
you've got to get rid of all the
impurities in stone and that's why the
models are so important and because you
need that 12 carat and you need the
color to be great and you want you to be
flawless we then take the real stone
market and put it on the wheel how long
does it take well it took months I mean
we've only just finished it and we're in
August and we got the stone in February
and you didn't wind up paying about 26
million for the uncut diamond how does
that compare to other big purchases that
you've made that's huge
is it your I think that's our biggest so
far in terms of value you know we've cut
bigger stones but but we've never cut a
stone at that value what do you hope to
sell it for we haven't gotten to that
yet you know it's historic it's rare so
you know the next step for us is to have
it at the Smithsonian to do the
scientific testing and then for it to go
to the Natural History Museum in Los
Angeles and we'll see from there but we
haven't actually sat down and done the
valuation yet but I mean it's tens of
millions of dollars as you can imagine
and we take a look at the broad supply
you know
DeBeers saying that hey this year we can
produce as much as 32 million carats of
diamonds is there enough demand for that
kind of supply yes where is it mostly
come from you know America's takes 40%
of the market
it's worth billions of dollars you're
talking about you know the bridal
industry you're talking about retailers
you know the top houses in the world
there's always a demand for diamond
jewelry synthetic diamonds are you
scared of them no and I'll tell you why
no because we don't call them synthetic
the people that have synthetic diamonds
we call it lab-grown so they're growing
it it's like a cultured pearl but it's
not actually the same and we're not
scared of it natural diamonds like this
diamonds the natural color diamond is
going to be more in demand for person
that wants something natural even though
that diamonds been lab-grown from from a
diamond it's not the same thing as
mother nature you have to inform people
that it's lab-grown
there's a legislation for that and it's
going to be enforced what's the growth
rate that you're expecting it seems like
global diamond jewelry sales have
increased threefold in the past 25 years
what's the growth rate you can predict
over the next looking at the market
because it can be volatile but I think
in diamonds and in jewelry you're
looking at a 10% increase that's what
I'm thinking on your terms of yeah
because you're looking at new people
coming into the market the Chinese
market is going to take a lot of the
product you know they're starting to get
into engagement rings that they want to
wear jewelry they want to wear you know
they want to be part of the whole
process so I think that's going to raise
the demand so it's I'm going to make
this into a ring it could be a ring it
could be a ring my husband was named
painted what we can call in what's his
knowledge